je le dis pour la première fois et iwuy
c'est léger comme un 10 1 ben je le dis
pour la commet je le dis pour la
première fois
parce que c'est elle et c'était sa
réponse il aimait
de 14 ans qui est un peu mais un peu
malade telle est la même chose et oui ça
l'est déjà pour combler missiles oui
alors du mali m avec un petit siège
prête vraiment intéressant et j'ai une
boule d'oc non mais c'est là qu'on voit
quand même tiré sa part m ce que le gars
qui est
bien quand même tu diras rien je raconte
quand même pas ce qu'ils racontent c'est
important c'est intéressant stéphane
plaza ça fait 15 ans 15 20 ans peut-être
qu'il est à l'antenne et que plusieurs
rumeurs circulent le concernant et des
hétéros homos bi sexuel etc certains
savent certains pensent avoir plein de
choses et là c'est la première fois
qu'il le dit il s'en est souvent un peu
amusé le dit officiellement dans les
colonnes du jdd le journal du dimanche
la rubrique qui s'appelle le dimanche 2
à chaque fois c'est un people différent
chaque chaque semaine la cellule et l'y
je suis à lille 17 petites phrases et
l'air de rien c'est pas anodin non à ce
schéma il dit pour la fois je suis
hétéro c'est vrai qu'il est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup il aux rumeurs et
russa après il en jouait il un joueur
énorme et justement moi je trouve ça
assez génial parce qu'il ya beaucoup des
terreaux dans le milieu de la télé puis
d'ailleurs n'importe où qui n'aimerait
pas du tout avoir cette réputation on se
dit est ce qu'ils sont homos ça les gêne
ça les met face à leur virilité lui il
en a joué pendant des années et jugement
et saihi sens il en joue tout le temps
je précédente journée ce que c'est pas
un jeu de travail et ordonnance non
c'est pas une question ajouter une crise
à d'autres en fait ils n'auraient
absolument pas honte s'il était gay il
donnerait aux gi lors aucun problème si
les t bills euros aucun problème en gros
la sexualité pour lui c'est anecdotique
mais en tout cas je peux vous dire une
chose c'est qu'il est 100% hétéro état
d'attenté bah non parce que je vois
c'est vraiment le hilali stigma scheiben
hétéro j'attends une pile aime les
choses j'ai une amie qui a une âme une
histoire avec lui pendant un moment a
donc il m'a confirmé qu'avec mais non tu
es un vrai ménage adore stéphane plaza
est ce qu'il a pu le coureur un peu dire
ce que c'est une salle marie venue c'est
une femme maria merde mais ces noms que
déjà des
démissions c'est gigantesque
stéphane plaza une aventure est bas
longtemps avec une femme mariée vincent
mcdoom ya longtemps c'était à combien de
temps mais si je c'était il ya longtemps
la bcc ya longtemps mais la dame est
évidemment non ce qui a trait au temps
quand on a fait pékin express ensemble à
lui loin devant moi quand même ils
avaient entre est vrai que toutes les
jeunes femmes qui regardent tous les
gens qui regardaient c'était des jeunes
femmes et sinon mes atouts c'est à dire
on n'en veut pas du tout d'être
hétérosexuel et donc franchement il est
adorable tout ça non le seul petit truc
qui a été un petit peu commenté c'est le
côté allez je vous annonce je vais je
suis hétérosexuel laissant un peu
entendre et ouais dans la télé il n'y a
pas que
webgl est l'agent a expliqué une partie
de blagues connaissance téva donc ils
égaient
façon de lui dire oui l attention
roulements de tambour sais pas jusqu'où
qui est aussi un second degré et parce
qu'ils avaient qu il avait même déclaré
je ne fais pas de différence entre un
homme et une femme j'éprouve autant de
plaisir avec l'un et l'autre aujourd'hui
je vis avec un homme je suis très
heureux ah pardon jean pierre coffe
la piste mais a pu apprécier les coming
out célèbre tu as donc tu prépares
trotteuse et mutin c'est impossible
seront repeints qu'il a déclaré
absolument absolument d'euros a
absolument aucun après la catherine lara
pierre palmade aucun rapport c'était
très drôle sauce et michel denisot qui
dit qu'est ce que vous regardez en
premier chez un homme élu réponse à la
détresse rôle